late morning and near a train station in
South London we've arranged to meet
three men who came to the UK to seek
Asylum they don't want us to know where
they're staying so you've all gone
underground all disappeared yeah living
outside of society
in a week which has seen the government
ratchet up its strategy to stop people
entering the country illegally we can
reveal threats to deport Asylum Seekers
to Rwanda were already driving those
here into hiding
is from India and flew to the UK using
fake documents I don't want to like
attend the home office to proceed my
clip you don't want to risk a risk no I
don't want to risk so what are you
afraid of that if you if you're 10 yeah
they may be like detained me and they
can send me to Rwanda
it means anyone in Authority like the
police terrifies them
I am very nervous and suffering and I
quoted I don't know
say they're tamils who fled from
persecution and torture in Sri Lanka
they crossed the channel by small boat
after risking their lives to get here
they're also now ditching their Asylum
claims I came to three items from what
second time three times yeah second time
supposed to be water you know like
you're capsized yeah he's pushed me out
of water then I assuming then sight
third time Third Time Lucky but did you
think that your life
your life like it is now on the Run not
now I not like it
but going into hiding can make it
difficult to access some medical care
and leaving the hotel accommodation
provided by the government for Asylum
Seekers whilst their claims are being
processed everyone that we've spoken to
says they're only really able to exist
outside of the system because they're
offered somewhere to live or given cash
in hand work by people they know within
their own community
for those Going Underground here's a
glimpse into the future tomorrow is the
day to taking all cardboards
Kanika sabbathy is paid cash in hand by
other Sri Lankans to do cleaning and
maintenance work
he came to the UK nearly 20 years ago
and also says he fled persecution he's
lived in this garage for five years
since his Asylum claim failed
he's very aware the home office is
stepping up raids on undocumented
migrants living illegally like him
it's a miserable and lonely existence
so for you this is a normal life this is
my local Idol I don't know what is the
difference because I'm struggling to
hear but this is my normal life do you
know a lot of people who live like you
live yeah I have a one or two friends
they are also League like that sometimes
they're sleeping on the on the road at
least I got something that's what I
think
it's estimated there could be around a
million migrants living illegally in
Britain fueling the cash in hand economy
another problem for a government
desperately trying to stop anyone else
from joining its broken Asylum system
Lisa Holland Skies